ladies and gentlemen welcome to an
exciting
wild ride where i talk to a guy who
knows pain
every bit as well as i do this dude has
a channel called
brave wilderness which i'm sure you've
seen because
god it is staggering how popular it is
his name is coyote peterson he's
impressive on every level
and now get ready to fall in love with
them the way i did
ladies and gentlemen coyote peterson
yeah dude hell yeah dude how you doing
man
i'm doing good steve how are you i'm
very well i want you to meet my co-host
scott randolph what's up cody hi nice to
meet you
and up at the front of the rv we've got
the gorgeous paul
briskey hello coyote how are you good
paul how are you man
i'm fantastic dude great to talk to you
okay
to start with where are you uh right now
i am in my home office
in columbus ohio how about you look warm
and toasty
i actually just got done doing yard work
believe it or not in december like
30 minutes ago uh there's no snow today
so i had to take that last opportunity
to get rid of the leaves that are
destroying my grass
nice man now columbus ohio that's uh
roman atwood
territory huh yep roman and i live
uh about a half hour from each other
okay and so i take it to
your bros uh yeah i mean i consider us
buddies we've done a couple of video
projects together every once in a while
get together for lunch
um yeah roman's a great dude i think uh
his ability to have transitioned from
just the world of pranks
into like the more family-friendly vlog
content that he did for
you know pretty significant number of
years there was a pretty awesome
transition in the world of youtube
big time man and i actually checked out
his channel
not long ago found that he's still very
much vlogging away
and and raking in the views man yeah as
far as i know
i haven't talked to him recently but um
you know to
keep up with the wave the way that he
does or he did consistently
every single day filming himself editing
himself
and posting that is a huge
responsibility he's not doing it every
day anymore
you know i think it's still consistent
but not every day
and this is not the roman atwood podcast
over here this is [ __ ] coyote
peterson man
so you're in columbus ohio is that is
that where you're from
yeah that's where our production company
is set up i went to school here at the
ohio state university
and pretty much have been in columbus
ever since so yeah i love columbus it
definitely takes good care of us yeah
well
[ __ ] man what kind of wildlife do you
run into in columbus like
growing up what would you see around
probably not the craziest stuff that you
would list
on a wild animal species never makes an
episode um
i would say my biggest uh my biggest
uh species to go after something called
the common snapping turtle steve
i know you've got some experience with
snapping turtles yourself
um i think you got bit in the butt by an
alligator snapping turtle if i remember
correctly
yeah it's uh the common snapping turtles
that we have here in ohio
and they are extremely aggressive super
fun to interact with
and they definitely got me my start when
it came to
going after wild animals i always say
that if steve irwin had the crocodile
coyote peterson had the common
yeah snap it's got an unfortunate name
common snapping turtle
is the common snapping turtle the one
where his tongue looks like a worm in an
attraction oh that's that's the
alligator snapping turtle
i posted this this crazy [ __ ] guy had
a huge snapping turtle and he went to
give it a kiss
and it just clobbered his nose is that a
common snapping turtle
yeah so i know that video you're talking
about and to be honest with you
there must be some aftermath to that
episode
there's no way you could get hit in the
face like that and bitten by a snapping
turtle
and not have it just open your face up
so i have a feeling that there's more to
that video footage
i wish i could see it because i
guarantee you there's blood spilling out
of his face
seconds after that yes this is your
question that's a common snapping
journal
it's like yeah it's a again an
unfortunate name because it should be
called like the behemoth [ __ ]
unbelievably badass snapping turtle
i'll tell you what you're right because
i think the name common comes with the
fact that like you can find them in
almost any like crazy swampy muddy body
of water
but they're super hard to find like
their camouflage their
elusive nature i mean they definitely
deserve something much better than the
name common snapping turtle
yeah for sure now when i posted that
video
like uh this is um i i can't remember if
i reached out to the guy ahead of time
and said hey can i post
this you know i generally am in that
practice
of getting permission from people one
way or another whenever it was
this guy uh you know was like hey you
know i live where you're going on tour i
want to you know
and uh we we met up with the guy he was
written he was in the green room like
while we were doing the show
which was kind of weird and like he was
super drunk
and it was like what city was his nose i
can't remember
but the thing was
that uh i i had people hit me up saying
yo
posting that snapping turtle video with
the guy
you know getting his nose bitten was
like super uncool of you
because as it played out
he was uh the way he handled the
snapping turtle
drew a lot of criticism yeah they said
that uh
that this guy was um you know it was an
inhumane
act as it played out which kind of
bummed me out you know i never want to
uh but yeah that was the story about the
aftermath was that he
was cruel to the but not that his
nose was missing or yeah
i mean i kind of wish that his nose
would have been missing
any time i hear somebody mistreats an
animal i'm like well i hope that comes
back around on you but
hugging a snapping turtle the way that
he was i mean he probably deserved to
get bit in the face so
hey be careful with turtles yeah dude
now i think uh
it's it's really pretty awesome
to think like i am trying
to try to articulate myself well here
like
the the the sting zone like a lot of the
stuff you're doing with
animal attacks is so reminiscent
of wild boys of jackass the stuff that
we do
but like as i check out your stuff
no part of me feels like oh man this
guy's [ __ ] like copying our stuff you
know like
i i really like the way that you do it
and and i
really applaud the amount of success
that you've achieved through doing that
that's cool man
i appreciate that that means a lot
coming from you i mean
it's very fair to say that i've been a
fan of your work and jackass as whole
since
i was in high school so you know you
guys certainly have a lot of influence
on
i would say anybody in the youtube space
to be honest with you that's
capable of making fast-paced engaging
content you guys sort of set the bar
before youtube was a thing so i won't
lie when i say we studied the formulaic
nature of jackass to be like okay
how do you keep this thing moving moving
moving moving with today
and everybody having the attention
deficit order that they do certainly
within the realm of tick tock but
even once youtube you know splashed onto
the scene
we were really looking at what can we do
in the world of animals and adventure
that will keep the audience
glued on you know what i mean like
certainly planet earth was out there you
know
creating these epic wildlife you know
documentaries but
when steve irwin passed away nobody was
engaging with wildlife
the way that steve had and you know of
course bear grylls with man versus wild
which is a show that i also love
bear was out there doing it with that
fast-paced style and editing and i won't
say similar to jackass but
bear was doing some pretty crazy extreme
stuff so when you take a combination of
steve irwin stevo and jackass and johnny
knoxville and bear grylls
and you mix it together we kind of saw
the formula for
animal adventure content but of course
with a lot of the education and science
spun into it
and not killing and eating animals but
teaching people about themselves right
yeah there's there's a lot of there's a
lot of homage there to you guys i would
say in a certain sense
i mean i i pick up on it and um
and and i can be very clear that for all
of the
kind of like half-assed copycat stuff
that that's popped up
i've never been psyched on it you know
it's just i i want to see
stuff that's done well i want to see
stuff that's uh
and you do your stuff well man and uh
and i appreciate that
so brave wilderness is that your company
is that
yeah so i own a handful of companies
myself and my business partner mark
um you know we were very strategic in
the way that we set up
everything that we do it's probably
important to note that my
background is in film screenwriting
producing and directing so
i've got a big business background and
filmmaking background before i even
stepped in front of a camera to be
honest i was not a person that ever
wanted to be in front of a camera
i always wanted to be the guy behind the
camera but then when the idea came about
for this
animal adventure series it was like well
coyotes the guy that knows a lot about
the animals
uh probably makes sense for him to be in
front of the camera at the same time
so brave wilderness is sort of our
mothership and then we've got multiple
uh sub companies underneath the parent
company
that you know are basically each asset
of the brand for the most part between
merchandising and the production house
and all that so i guess that's a
more long-winded boring story when it
comes to the business side but we're
very strategic in the way that we set
everything up
dave that the uh the video description
on the youtube of this conversation
let's say
coyote peterson you take steve irwin you
take
stevo and [ __ ] rob durdik
yeah mr businessman over here it's great
when you guys are when you guys are
filming like uh something with
venomous whatever do you know that
you're not going to have an allergic
reaction beforehand like when you're
you know going to get stung by something
like because you were worried about
anaphylaxis with the murder hornet or
he wasn't worried about it he said it
was a possibility
to answer to answer your question the
answer is no
i don't ever know and i think certainly
for the audience that's that one thing
it's just like
a is this guy really going to go through
with this
b we know that he's going to and when he
does what's the worst case scenario
that's going to happen
um but we do a lot of research ahead of
time to say
okay how many people have died from this
bite or this sting
what are the odds that that's going to
be my card that gets pulled
and then of course we always have
medical professionals on standby
sometimes on location sometimes just
that we've alerted medical centers in
the area that we're filming to say hey
we're going to do this so you know if we
come rushing to you this is what happens
let's talk about it i thought that was a
fancy way of saying we do
have a cell phone in our pocket
[Laughter]
now dude let me let me tell you
something crazy because it really speaks
to
uh scott's question too when we were
when we were filming wild boys
uh you know our jackass spin-off nature
show which was uh
you know interns turn's homoerotic and a
lot of
animal attack kind of stuff and but
still brilliant in its own right i will
say i've
i've seen it all so i'm very well aware
well thank you very much
um so the the short story is that we
traveled to every continent
on the planet except for antarctica
and essentially got stung by
you know like scary things
on every continent to travel the whole
world we did four seasons of it
that was before uh jackass number two
now on jackass number two after four
seasons of wild boys
they came up with the idea to uh
to have um the the the guys
and under arrows get into a stretch
limousine
and then once in the stretch limousine
the doors will be locked
they'll throw in a beehive through the
sunroof and then
you know you're trapped in the the b
limousine
right but somehow there's such a
different maybe it's because it's a
union deal
and maybe because wild boys was just
half ass in general
but this was the first time because it
was for the movie
that each and every cast member had to
get
uh tested for allergies
to bee stings and so we all get the
the allergy test for bee stings and
pontius who traveled with me getting
stung all over the world
came back unbelievably allergic
to basics they said they said he is so
allergic you cannot let them get
stung and uh and we found that out after
the fact
and the results from my bee sting test i
don't know
why they said it but they said pontius
is very allergic
stevo does not seem to be human
yeah so i so that's why pontius wasn't
in the beehive limo
and uh and they were [ __ ] crazy have
you ever had one of those tests
it's a great question no doubt but not
nearly as important as the one i'm about
to ask you
have you taken the test or should i say
quiz at helix sleep.com
why is it so important because it only
takes like a couple minutes to put in
your personal information
and then they tell you what is the best
most
comfortable rest worthy mattress
that you can get that's right folks
helix
mattresses this is just my favorite
thing
ever oh and i want you to try it because
you're gonna just sleep better you're
gonna feel more rested
your body's gonna thank you so how do
you take this quiz
go to helix sleep dot
com slash stevo fill out the quiz
order yourself a mattress if you do it
this way
you're gonna get up to 200.
off of any mattress and
two free pillows and i'm telling you the
pillows are
just as good as the mattress so how are
you gonna do it
helix sleep.com stevo for up to 200
off of any mattress and two free pillows
you're gonna thank me for it now let's
talk about the test
i haven't but i went through a pretty
extreme
b scenario um i don't know if you ever
saw the episode where
it was called bb or gone wrong where i
attempted to wear a bee beard for the
first time
i've done this more than once but the
first time that i did it uh
long story short is it was a combination
of european honeybees
and somehow africanized or killer bees
got mixed in
and the two different b types got in a
fight on my
face so as soon as a bee stings
it releases a pheromone that something
is happening and it alerts the other
bees
to also attack so i'm in the process of
wearing this beard and the guy that i
was working with he said you know he's a
professional he does this honeybee thing
all the time
i was like dude i'm getting stung a lot
and he's like are you sure i'm like
yeah this is really starting to get bad
i mean they were covering my face
and i'm getting stung in multiple places
and finally i was like
i was like dude i gotta call it i had
gotten stung
like 60 times on my face and neck and
arms you know they were getting into my
eyes and my face swelled up like an
overcooked hot dog i mean it looked like
i had lip injections i thought my
lips were gonna explode and they had
gotten so swollen so
yeah bee venom the point of this story
is that b venom is
very unique in the insect kingdom and
more people are allergic usually to bee
stings than they are most other insects
stings
so would you be allergic to a scorpion
sting if you were allergic to bee stings
not likely it's not impossible but not
likely each venom is unique
unto its own so if you're deathly
allergic donnie bees it doesn't mean
you're going to be allergic to bullet
ants
or hornets or wasps or anything like
that
yeah bullet ants [ __ ] so we were uh on
tour so
i could never keep track of where things
happened but uh
black widow the black widow what is it
like
how about that okay so we're in this
we're on tour this kid says
dude i found a black widow spider in my
uh
car and i was able to capture it
in this little like petri disc looking
thing
and uh he says can i go grab it and i'm
like [ __ ] yeah i could grab a black
winter spot
sure enough he's got the black widow and
uh
and i'm like okay like i'll put it in my
mouth you know
and uh everybody thought like oh this is
crazy and i'm thinking like
what's the big whip you know because uh
i remember it it would have been so epic
but somehow we
like didn't get the shot of it coming
out but i so
fully had it in my mouth closed my mouth
i like
i bobbed my head around a little bit and
then i opened my mouth and it came out
and and nothing ever happened i didn't
get stung by it um
but uh then i yeah i went over to my
buddy dr drew i said what do you think
about this and he was like you
you what so i guess i feel like you're
probably a better
expert to ask than dr drew what would
happen what would it
what would happen if that black widow
stung me well
at first it would have bitten you it
wouldn't have stung you because
they don't sting it's probably also
worth noting that the black widow is the
second most venomous spider
in the united states not likely to kill
you
but i don't know what would happen if it
bit you in your mouth like most of the
time people
get bitten on their foot or their
fingers um we actually have an episode
coming out
uh i think next weekend where i free
handle a black widow spider
at night we've done this once before
where i free handled it during the day
video did bonkers numbers of you so
we're like well let's do it at night
because spiders are scarier at night
and they're a pretty docile species
which is why i'm comfortable handling
them
would never recommend anybody else to it
but if you're bitten
in your mouth that's close to like your
throat and your brain
that can be really bad really quickly
again it's all about how your body
reacts to the venom and i mean with the
stuff you've been through stevo i mean i
feel like
you could probably get bitten by a black
widow and turn into like the next
version of
spiderman or venom or something like
that so in your video do you get bit by
the
black widow spider no absolutely not no
if you were bitten what is guaranteed to
happen
is about 36 to 48 hours of
intense pain vomiting sweating
cramping in your stomach um it's
probably arguably one of the worst
like venom non-snake bite scenarios you
could go through in the united states
you're gonna wish you weren't bitten if
you were and like i said that's people
getting bitten on like their foot or
their hands so in their mouth
yeah it would have been a bad day for
you and what's that what's the number
one the brown recluse is the poisonous
yeah brown so the broad recluse has
necrotic
components to its venom which means it
will actually rot a hole
in your skin the black widow might swell
up a little bit but it's not going to
actually break down your flesh at all so
the brom recluse
is like for an arachnid it's up there
with like
a rattlesnake now rattlesnake is much
more likely gonna kill you
but both of them will will actually
break down your your cell structure
man rattlesnakes scare me so much
especially because here my uh
companion wendy who's on my lap right
now um
the idea of uh if she got bitten by a
rattlesnake
and if anything happened to wendy like
i'm just straight up not gonna be okay
and and uh we live in the hollywood
hills
where there's [ __ ] rattlesnakes man
my
i i got on tick tock my first tick tock
video i posted
was of two rattlesnakes mating like
on the street like right by my house ah
so well here here's a good thing to know
um
and again venom affects humans and
animals completely differently
uh my mom actually lives in tucson
arizona she has a golden
a couple of golden retrievers her dogs
have been bitten by rattlesnakes more
than once
and managed to survive just fine dogs
fight off venom
differently than humans do that's
certainly not to say that you should
ever not take every uh medical emergency
step
with wendy if she would ever be bitten
but she would
most likely be okay if she was bitten
fingers crossed that she never gets
bitten yeah you gotta take her to the
hot my uncle's dog got bit right in the
nose by rattlesnake and
i said dude that's what that's the worst
thing like i [ __ ]
i i uh like googled it what happens if a
dog gets bitten by rattlesnake and like
80 90 of the time it is right on their
nose because they're curious and they go
up to a nose first take her to the
rattlesnake classes
okay so the rattlesnake classes work
it's like aversion therapy they're gonna
like
put a rattlesnake near her and then like
zap her with a cattle prod or something
to
give her negative associations with the
rattlesnake is that what they do
you know i've never heard that before
but the first thing i thought it was man
people will find any way that they
possibly can to make money but i can't
discredit it because
i know nothing about it and all i can
say is that
if a dog relates dogs are smart right so
if they relate
uh this snake or this shape or this
sound with getting zapped there's a good
point a chance that
uh they won't go near that again i'm
sure it's probably based on the sound
of the rattlesnake as compared to a
visual or a smell
because that sound is something you know
dogs are so in tune with their noses and
their ears probably before they are
their eyesight
so yeah i mean i could see that working
i don't know give it
give it a whirl and let us know i don't
want anybody to zap
my girl no that's that's what i would
say the
zap might be worse than anything yeah
and then is there such a thing as a
preemptive uh
what do you call it like not a
vaccination but antidote
like i know that you can get some kind
of an anti-venom
after the fact but is there a preemptive
one that
no there's not and one important thing
that i should probably
note about anti-venom especially when it
comes to venomous snakes
people do not realize how expensive
that is like if you are a person who is
just like oh you know i've got a normal
nine to five job and some decent health
insurance and you get bit by like a
western diamondback rattlesnake
it could bankrupt you that is how
expensive anti-venom is
and depending how your body reacts or
how much the venom yield
came from with the snake you could
require multiple bodies of anti-venom
that can before you know it run you up
well over six figures to save your life
so
uh getting bit by rattlesnake is a very
very serious thing
yeah it is manny lost his pinky that way
no
there wasn't his pinky manny the shark
guy from uh
wild boys he he lost he's a permanent
shakka oh yeah that's like a jerry
garcia
yeah he got that pyramid like uh it's so
[ __ ] funny um so is it anti-venom
or venom like um to be honest i'm not
sure if there's a
proper way to to list it i mean i've
always used anti-venom but i think it's
kind of like tomato tomato
i think they're kind of both the same
thing but don't quote me on that because
there might be a slight subtle
difference
and it may have to do with the kind of
snake or how it was processed
a lot of a lot of people don't realize
that the process to make anti-venom
serum is a whole huge crazy scientific
world of processes that's not as easy as
like oh we took venom from a snake and
mixed it up in a bottle and now it
magically can cure you
right i feel like all those like venom
like getting bit by [ __ ] like
really actually helps your body out in
the long run like build out like certain
antibodies and just kind of overall for
health like a good health cocktail would
be
get stung by [ __ ] right like your
blood charts should be off the charts
right
you know my mom makes that joke with me
all the time that maybe like we should
take my blood and find out if it has any
like
magical purposes to like help cure
people of other
strange things that i tell you that
sounds crazy but
i will say that during the process of i
don't know
2016 until now the number of bites and
stings and possible infections that i've
staved off
um i don't know man knock on wood i
never get sick and i do attest some of
it to probably my body
fighting off these foreign invaders that
come in the form of venom or bacteria
that gets bitten into my system with
stuff but
you know stephen i think it's probably
fair to maybe ask you that same question
to say are you somebody that's usually
pretty healthy considering the things
you put yourself through
and your natural antibodies fight all
that off and build up a resistance
uh absolutely man i think that as a
general rule
uh the more that we challenge our immune
system the stronger it's gonna be i
think that the immune system is very
much a muscle
and you know muscles work out they get
stronger you gotta
like uh it was resistance training so it
follows that
um you know in my view like germs are
good
you know like i'm the least germaphobic
person ever
i i i love germs i i
let me ask you this let me ask you this
i i just have to know because you have
to be the only human in history that's
ever been
slingshotted into the air in a porta
potty did
any negative recourse come of that like
when i saw that clip
i was like how is this humanly possible
that you didn't get some sort of crazy
diseases from being inside of a
portable whirlpool like that there's uh
the the thing about that again because
it was a movie and like with the second
movie we had to get everybody uh
you know there's much more like osha
sort of regulation
and uh with the bees you had to get the
allergy test
with the the movie which this was the
third movie where i did the porta-potty
slingshot
and the rule was no human poo
no no human poo but dog poo
was totally okay and i'm so glad that
this comes up right now because i
just checked with uh our shady prop guy
jp
who's in charge of get of sourcing all
the stuff
and he and i always knew that there was
a company
that that you could go to and buy as
much
dog poo as you want which they did i
forget if it was 50 pounds
what it like how much but they bought
enough dog poo to fill up that porta
potty
and the name of that company i just
checked with jd
jp the name of that company is
we do do do
we do do do do i don't i'm not wondering
where they get it all or
they have like a farm of just dogs
[ __ ] like i have no idea dude i have
no idea and i don't know that they're
still in business
that guy how do you get into that line
of work like i said people will find
anything they can to possibly find a way
to make a dollar i mean
i would have never even thought that
that could be a possibility right to go
on
like dog poop and be like we're going to
sell it to people making movies
right i have no idea what other purpose
there could possibly be
for buying a wholesale dog poop
but i think the answer to your question
is that um
the the the osha regulations kind of got
it right
in that human poo is much more riddled
with diseases
yeah than dog but i think dog poo is uh
is a lot cleaner
and even if it was human poo i wouldn't
care i would have done it filled with
human poo
i honestly i don't know i i would have i
would have done
it joyfully with human poo because i
would have in my
view been challenging my immune system
even more
right
he has done it with his own human poo oh
yeah
for sure but uh but but but in any case
so
you told me that the mothership is
is brave wilderness underneath the
mothership you've got all these
ancillary companies you're evidently a
very savvy businessman
uh routinely on your youtube channel
which has 18 million subscribers you've
got
videos that have 40 and 50 million views
so uh the simple
question is what's the like the the
main source of revenue for all of your i
know it's a shitty
like uh intrusive question but we would
never
be so rude as to ask somebody the
numbers of their business
we just want percentages
so uh adsense revenue for you you're
very frank
even though you've got this like edgy
i'm getting stung and bitten by
everything
you're uh still within that family
friendly zone so your adsense revenue is
probably
a pretty high on the cpm meter unlike
mine
and uh and with the amount of viewership
you've got adsense has to be a
pretty good chunk of revenue and and
your merchandising is is pretty on fire
look at that face dude
do you do a lot of uh like branded
integration
deals you have like uh uh
yeah i mean i'll go ahead go ahead
finish i'm trying to figure out what
exactly
is the tv show i'm happy today i mean
i'm just yeah
then of course there's the actual
production for for television you got
the animal planet
series you got uh you know presumably
all kinds of uh
you know outside of youtube
media production so so what you're
asking steve is how do these revenue
streams rank what's not yeah
yeah yeah yeah we'll be exactly thank
you paul
i gotcha you're gonna guest it is
is that the top three revenue streams
the adsense the march and the
the television production yeah to be
honest with you
tv and i'm sure you guys have
experienced this from a lot of projects
you've done that the
crazy thing that most people don't
realize about television in general is
like
you get a big bucket of money but then
you spend that all
very quickly for all of the pieces parts
that really
really shake out we managed to produce
our youtube content on a
very very tight budget and that's
because we do something called
batch producing which is probably
similar to how you guys did jackass in
those early seasons where
you know we go to a location and we just
crush it i mean we get as much content
as we possibly can
and the crazy thing about youtube is
that yeah you can go to the brave
wilderness channel and you can see that
you know there's videos that have you
know 20 30 40 50 million views
obviously we know that the the sweet
spot with our content
is when is coyote gonna do something
extreme like
recently we just did a two back-to-back
episodes where
i was eaten alive by sea lamprey i don't
know if you guys ever did something with
sea lamprey but they're this
primitive looking fish species with a
suction cup for a mouth 150 teeth
and a sort of cheese grater for a tongue
and they suction onto fish
cut holes in them and then suck their
blood and fluids out so
of course i was like well let's find out
what will happen if i stick those to me
and right now those are two of our most
popular episodes that just came out last
weekend for
thanksgiving that we know those are what
we call tent poles right so
in using entertainment terms we produce
a certain number of videos every year
that we know are going to be those tent
poles
big views big dollars and the way that
those work
is that the library as a whole is
probably the thing that's the most
valuable to brave wilderness when i say
the library
i mean the 640 plus videos what's
interesting about
animals specifically is that they're
golden they're evergreen
like it doesn't matter if i made an
episode about an american badger in 2014
in 2020 the american badger is the same
exact thing
and the facts have stayed the same so
all of these videos are
constantly getting watched right every
single day
but if you put out a tent pole like the
sea lamprey
that hits the channel and then it goes
into overdrive
the whole thing lifts it's like the tide
rising right so
all of the other episodes on the channel
rise around it
and then you see the views start coming
in and they're cranking and they're
cranking and their subs are cranking
and that's what you want the channel to
do a youtube channel is a machine it's
like a locomotive
and if you stoke that fire and you rev
up that engine
and you get that thing going and then
you keep throwing more onto it
it grows and grows and grows that's how
we grew the channel
but that's also how we have these big
influxes of views and views
um every single month and we
strategically plan
on a monthly basis how we're going to
drop certain videos so when i say to you
guys
next week we're probably dropping that
black widow free handling episode
we may drop that next week but we may
also hold on to it to the next week
based on how the channel is doing
we also have an episode called eaten
alive by piranhas which is a follow-up
to the sea lamprey
that's also on deck so we try to get
enough content
built up so that we can almost throw our
cards down strategically
to figure out how to make the channel do
what it does does that make sense
i love it yeah are you posting once a
week or
twice a week once once to twice a week
which is tough
considering all the content that we make
is original content
it's done on location or out in the wild
or or sometimes in a production studio
um but everything we do
if we do production studio it's very few
in in in between um
but we love it man it's it's the
challenge that keeps us going and
the audience really drives you to try to
up your ante to the next round i mean
again i don't mean to throw it back to
jackass in comparison but
i'm sure as you guys were making videos
each one of those little segments you're
like man
that one was a hit how are you going to
get that next hit and then you start
getting into the movies and you're like
how's the next one going to be a hit
it's all it's all like a video game for
us at the end of the day but the cool
thing about our video game is that we're
educating people about animals promoting
conservation and
we get to do it with our buddies so we
love it it's cool
i love doing this podcast because we
routinely
talk to wildly successful people and we
learn about
how they think and and and what they do
and
and i think that i think our podcast is
really
becoming that a study of success
yeah what an honor how many videos in
the can do you have
ready to go at this point uh we have a
backlog of 14 episodes
on tap right now ready to go and
yeah and first of all steve let me just
say thank you for asking these kinds of
questions because i'm always happy to
talk about
bites and stings but i thrive on getting
to talk the business side of things
because
people usually don't have any interest
in that so i'm i'm happy to talk about
this sort of stuff
um but our backlog of content that we
have right now
when we get into the winter months
that's where we slow down a little bit
on production because you know a lot of
animals go into hibernation
obviously right now with covet it's
making it difficult to travel
internationally but
right now our next production trip is
slated for costa rica in january and
like we've got a slate
of content we hope to get and i say hope
to get because with animals
you never know what's going to happen
like we don't stay anything like we go
for it
maybe we're going to get it maybe we
don't but you know hopefully we'll get a
good
a good burst of content on that trip
which of course will then keep us
chugging into spring and then
productions take off from there man i i
gotta say i'm tempted to
to try to collab with you on something
man like uh
i think that i think that we could we
could probably put together some pretty
sweet numbers if we did that
well coyote you talked about batch
producing are you ever getting bit
twice in a day like doing like okay wow
okay
that's a great question um thus far
i have been extremely fortunate to have
unbelievably competent camera operators
and before we go through with these
stings and bites
man do we make sure that we've got the
shot set up so that i don't
have to do it more than once yeah um
i can i can say to you that the bullet
ant the warrior wasps the executioner
wasp
giant desert centipede all of those were
a one and done
sort of scenario um the sea lampreys
strangely enough the one that just came
out
while what you see in the episode is all
natural as it played out but to get the
actual
thumbnail for the um the second episode
i had to let a sea lamprey suction onto
my neck
multiple times to the point where like
it had sucked so much blood to the
surface and it cut me so many times
that that probably should have been the
episode because there was so much blood
just to get the thumbnail that it was
far worse than what happened in the
actual website
wow i respect the integrity of that and
then so you go into these bites like
pretty educated
you know you kind of know what you're
getting into what has been
the biggest surprise you're like oh my
god we did not expect this much pain or
this kind of reaction
the giant desert centipede man people
always ask me you know
people a usually can't differentiate
between bites and stings and it's
important to note that the giant
centipede
is a bite and with the centipede
specifically i have a friend that i work
with in arizona
who has been bitten by rattlesnakes
multiple times
but was also accidentally once bitten by
a centipede and told me dude
it was so bad i was in the hospital uh
don't do it just don't do it i would
never wish that pain upon anybody i'm
like yeah yeah okay whatever
that's that's wonderful i'm gonna do it
anyways because i know the audience
wants to see it
my goodness man the bite from the giant
desert centipede
was the worst pain i've ever experienced
and the way that the venom works
is once it enters your system it gets
itself
inside of your blood cells and
essentially explodes them
from the inside out and you can feel
that happening
as it's taking effect and it it lasts
for hours
i went through nine insane hours of pain
where like
you can't sit still you have to walk
around like shaking your arm
before the point where i finally threw
up the white flag went to
a medical emergency center and of course
they gave me a
really good adult prescription advil
that uh
i took all of it within like two days to
get through the pain so i was just kind
of in a state of delirium
for about 48 hours and then it was over
oh my god so what's the difference with
the bite and the sting like how does the
venom
i mean obviously the sting is it comes
from its butt and a
bite comes from its mouth was that right
but but like how is it
i mean but how is the venom injected is
it
like where do they store the venom in
their mouth versus
in their body and their cheek great
great question so steve you're
absolutely right
butt versus mouth and a bite
with venom is usually used to kill and
subdue prey whereas the sting is used as
a defense so
when you've got something like a bee or
a hornet or a bullet in
a sting is used to drive something off
to be like don't mess with me
i stung you now i can get away with a
bite it's a much
higher venom yield and it's used to kill
something specifically
so the giant desert centipede which is
arguably one of the creepiest
creatures that lives in the united
states or anywhere around the world
they have an unbelievably high venom
yield for their body size
and they bite and bite and bite so it's
not like a rattlesnake that will
hit a rat and be like boom gotcha and
then the rat will run off
the snake will then track that rat down
and eat it once the venom
has taken it over a centipede will wrap
itself around its prey
and bite and bite and bite and just pump
that thing full of venom so
yeah it's not fun fun experience um is
there an elusive
uh wait real quick on the stings
it's the bees really got the short end
of the stick
from mother nature because they sting
defensively but once their stinger comes
out they die
so they they can protect themselves once
and and do bees
sting other bees like is that does that
happen
uh no not necessarily so the hive
structure of
of honey bees is a really intricate
thing and yeah i mean you're gonna feel
bad any time a bee stings and it's
dies afterwards but honeybees are
literally produced by the tens of
thousands
every single day so no they don't sting
necessarily for
um you know each other but uh stinger is
a modified ova posture basically so
that's what the female uses to actually
deposit eggs
male insects don't have stingers which
is
a pretty important thing to note i guess
so um it's most of the time it's if
you're stunned by something it's
i'm not going to say in every instance
there may be some insects that have
males with stingers but
99 of the time it's a female that's
stinging you
nice um with it
and it's crazy how speaking of mother
nature
like sort of rattlesnakes it just seems
like such
[ __ ] overkill like rattlesnake
venom is like come on they eat rodents
like a rattlesnake that's
judge like right where it has the power
to kill like a horse
right you know a ticket king cobra a
king cobra can kill an elephant
like what's a king cobra eating that
needs that much venom what's a rat like
what
why do they have such overkill
uh and you know it's a good question i
mean king cobras specifically are
labeled the king of snakes because they
primarily eat
other snakes when it comes to
rattlesnakes a lot of it just has to do
with evolution i mean it's fair to say
that the rattlesnake
is the most highly evolved snake species
on the planet so
it's considered a new world snake right
the united states like north america and
uh into central america that's the only
place in the world that rattlesnakes
exist
so they've got this defense mechanism
that's the rattle which
from most animals that they would face
that warning like a dog right here or a
wild animal is like
whoa that's a rattle i've gotten hit by
that once before i'm never going to get
near it again
but the hinged fangs and the venom are
such an evolved state as compared to
several other snake species and then
they've got those heat
sensing pits on the front of their face
as well so basically
all they need to do is bite something
and then they can let that thing run off
and then they can just track it down so
it's really
it really puts them in this perfect
position to not ever get
injured when they're battling against
their prey i mean for a lot of animals
even something like a lion think of how
many lions get killed every year because
they get kicked in the face by a zebra
you know so anytime an animal is able to
hit its prey
and then that prey is going to run off
mistakes like yep got my job done
it's kind of like it's a sharpshooter
you know it's like a stealth fighter
and then they can just track it down
it's already dead when they show up boom
and they've got their meal
they i i had never before thought of how
many lions die because they get kicked
in the face by zebra
yeah that's my first time
more than you think yeah i've seen it
happen
um the uh like for the scorpions
that i've been stung by think that
they've been exclusively
african emperor scorpions and that
sounds like
you know talk about a insect that scored
on a name
the african emperor scorpion sounds so
dope
but really a sting from the african
emperor scorpions
[ __ ] compared to like one of the
scorpions you'll find in arizona
right yeah so you know the emperor's
scorpion
it's uh perception can be everything so
they're about as scary looking as it
gets but they're really a pretty docile
species and very unlikely to sting
humans
unless strongly provoked now the venom
toxicity not to discredit any stings
you've been taken by
it's not super hot not compared to like
bark scorpions that live
in the southwestern united states so
within the u.s
there's three pretty notable scorpions
the giant desert harry scorpion which
is big and scary looking but no more
potent than that of really a honeybee
the striped-tailed scorpion which is a
tiny little scorpion and isn't that
powerful
but the bark scorpion is the one that if
you got stung by it
you could be in pain for several weeks
it's a really really bad state
wow and i'm gonna guess that that bark
scorpion is probably not an impressive
size
insect right nope nope they have very
small little dainty looking pinchers you
know their little
claw hands up front um because they
don't need to actually grab and
crush and really hold on to their prey
the second they sting something like a
rattlesnake
they'll let go of it and that victim is
going to fall
to that venom so quickly that the
scorpion really doesn't have to do much
of anything other than hit it and like
back up and be like all right we'll let
you die now and then when you're dead
i'm going to come in the meantime
my girl found a uh scorpion in our
bathroom
and it was tiny and like she freaked out
and i'm like what are you worried about
and she's like i walk in the bathroom in
the dark maybe i'm going to step on it
i'm like whatever you know
but in my mind i'm also thinking because
it's a small score i've been
because we're in the southwest united
states it's probably pretty [ __ ]
badass
i didn't let onto her that uh that i
considered it
serious has your girl ever been stung by
a trouser trout
um okay now like you said that you've
got
coming up uh the eaten alive by piranhas
and we've tried our asses off to get
eaten alive by piranhas
in both the amazon in a dunk tank in
oregon because we we could only shoot
the
piranha dunk tank in oregon because it's
illegal to have
piranhas like anywhere else but the
thing is
they're they only eat dead [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] scavengers
how do you try your ass they get eaten
well i mean
you fill a [ __ ] dunk tank with
piranhas and then and then they throw
the ball and you [ __ ] fall in
and the piranhas want absolutely nothing
whatsoever to do with you
when we were in the amazon river trying
to get eaten by piranhas
the the the piranhas were the least of
the concern or what the concern
was was that there's some kind of
[ __ ] organism
that will crawl down your dick hole and
then get in your bloodstream and like
fully kill you you're absolutely right
and to be
completely honest with you i thought
that i got that organism
right up that hole when we were filming
the animal planet series braved the wild
in the amazon well actually we're in the
ponto now so
still south america um and not to
tangent onto that because i was in the
water
with piranhas and filming um uh the
jacka day cayman which is a crocodile
species that's there and uh i
for peeing in my wetsuit is what ended
up happening i like burnt the inside of
my pee tube
but i thought that i got something up in
there from swimming around in this mucky
water
because it was burning when i was peeing
lo and behold
it was just that i you shouldn't pee in
your run super well wrong
combined together like that because i
guess you can like steer the inside of
your urethra from your own
didn't know that until it happened but
so i guess that was a long way to get to
the question
how did you uh get any footage out of
piranha when we've been
like so uh what do you call it uh well
let's just say this episode
definitely has blood and i don't want to
give away too much
but i will say that it is not what you
expect and you're absolutely right
piranha want nothing to do with humans
but unless they show you just how sharp
the teeth of a piranha are
don't worry it's we we had to
strategically design this episode
um because we know people want to see a
result
right like if you click on a video and
you're like oh you know i buy piranhas
well i expect somebody to get eaten
there's got to be something there so
we always deliver we don't ever like to
be in that position where it's like oh
you guys click baited me nothing happens
so yeah there is some blood but it
doesn't come across the way that you
would expect
i i feel very strongly about the click
bait thing i think uh
the good the good will that i i
have worked so hard to build with my
audience
is uh more important to me than than
trying to get one video to perform if
it's not there
exactly well and you you know that
better than anybody i mean you guys
you guys for all intents and purposes
created the sense
of viral videos and there are a lot of
people that
unrightfully so create viral videos that
are clickbait and
one of the ways that brave wilderness
was able to you know i think
build to the level of success that it
did was because
we had these great thumbnails and these
great titles and people are like dude
there's no way this dude's getting
stunned by this thing or bit by this
thing
and then once people would watch one
video and they're like oh man like that
that legit happened
and i saw it happen right there's no
movie magic here
then people believed in it and when you
deliver on the promise which
you know stevo you and the guys always
do you become legit at that point so
people
people trust in it yeah my dad raised me
with uh
with a motto which is like
never over promise and under deliver
you always want to under deliver sorry
under promise and over deliver
and yeah the the 10 out of 10 shoe
the guys yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right um
well i have a question oh sorry i just
want to wrap up what i was asking for
like if i heard you correctly adsense
revenue is at the top of the heap the
number one revenue stream
uh it's it's up there at the top yeah i
would say it's in the top three
is fair to say um but again you know we
we tried to very carefully structure the
way that we
approach the audience we do our best to
keep it family friendly
we love to be able to educate all
generations i mean we look at it as like
man we know kids love animals
and if we can get the parents to also
show up and watch the animals with their
kids and be like
huh yeah this is palatable for everybody
then we feel like we're doing the right
thing so it doesn't see it
it doesn't seem like sugar coated or
[ __ ] like i think
you do you do a great job of that um
that now
uh you say it's up there is like merch
is pretty up there too huh
yeah the merchandise side of things you
know it splits off into multiple
different tracks beyond merchandise
because there's
you could be talking about t-shirts you
could be talking about backpacks you
could be talking about
you know we've got an entire literary
division that we do with books
um we've got a video game and
development right now they have an
actual legit budget um you know and just
a bunch of other things not to mention
always trying to develop what's going to
be the next big project
so we did the television series with
animal planet and that was a
wonderful experience i have nothing
negative to say about the education i
got from that
but what we ultimately ended walking
away from with at the end of the day
it's like
people just really aren't watching
conventional cable television the way
that they used to we're not able to
reach the audience through
right cable tv like we can in the
digital space so
it for us it didn't make a lot of sense
to continue producing a series
of that caliber that wasn't reaching
enough eyeballs i think most television
networks are
pairing up with streaming platforms
to get that second window of an audience
you know like
fx on hulu and and such so
they have to now because 200 000 views
just
right so so with the physical merch the
t-shirts the backpacks the books
um are you doing like a monthly drop is
that like
the way that you keep the the blood
flowing like
do you have like a scheduled drop that's
as strategic as with your
videos like
merchandise is it like a regimented
monthly like new item that you work on a
schedule
uh like you do with your videos um not
necessarily i mean we certainly align
things strategically based on holiday
season kids going back to school
people wearing t-shirts during the
spring or you know needing backpacks at
back to school time versus
uh you know in right in the middle of
of april when school is about to be over
for the year so
um you know there's obviously a lot of
strategy put behind everything that we
do but
not the way that we strategize with with
the videos because playing the youtube
game is
far different than playing the
merchandise game the merchandise game is
you try to keep stuff original and fresh
and constantly having something new
and you hope that the audience likes it
i mean the one thing that
not to sound corny but i gotta give a
lot of love to our audience
is that you know they're consistent and
as
long as we can continue producing
content and cool stuff for them they
seem to be very happy so yeah
try to keep them happy yeah you know
with the merge thing it's like you get
the double beer
construction helmet for spring break
that one's coming out this holiday
season thank you
so much for your help
um and uh and how do you fulfill the
orders
of the physical emergence do you have a
third third party fulfillment center
uh so i've got a we've got an entire
merch team that's a part of
basically our our mothership it's a
subdivision of brave wilderness
um and we've got partners that do some
of the fulfillment but we're actually in
the process of now
probably bringing it in um in-house
full-time we're expanding from
the office we're in now to a much larger
space at the beginning of this next year
and
really beefing up our merch side this
year we're investing a lot back
into it simply because like you know
when i was a kid man like my whole
office is filled
full of the things that i collected as a
kid toys and merchandise like i'm one of
those weird collector kind of students
and um you know we want to create that
same exact legacy
for the kids that are growing up on
brave wilderness i mean i grew up on
steven spielberg and george lucas
teenage mutant ninja turtles jurassic
park star wars all of it so
that kind of like bleeds through me
constantly to try to follow in those
footsteps
yeah dude well hey man i'm i'm cool i'm
totally impressed
paul did i cut you off on my question i
do have a question actually yeah like uh
similar to jackass and what steve does
even though it's not everything you do
but there's sort of this escalating
pressure to like step your game up
all the time and have you ever had to
put your foot down where like your
producer mark is like yo man like
let's get you bit by a bear or something
you're like no dude
have you ever had to kind of like put
your foot down
no i mean the only time i'd say i i ever
put my foot down was once when i was
pitched a tv show
that actually turned into a tv show that
they did with some other people of me
getting bit and maimed by
some much worse things and i was like
dude there's there's no reason to do
that like we know the formula that works
and there's only a certain level you can
go to before people just look at it and
they're like yeah
you're just being stupid like if i were
to go out there and catch a juvenile
great white shark and be like well let's
see what happens when i put my arm in
its mouth yeah i can tell you what's
gonna happen it's gonna lacerate my arm
and i might die you know
like you never take it that far because
that's when you lose the audience like
you go way too beyond what they want to
see and then they're like come on dude
enough is enough yeah
we have a word for that it's dark
what about the what about a man or war
um well here's here's the thing about
jellyfish as a whole we
we're likely going to do a jellyfish
episode the problem with the jellyfish
episode
and we we analyzed this earlier on is
that you don't see enough
the way that we've really gotten a lot
of these episodes to be those viral hits
is i'm going to throw it back to steven
spielberg and like that movie magic
right that
edge of your seat suspense with the
editing and the music and the sound
effects and you're like man i'm going to
see this happen it's that car wreck
moment
that people want to experience or they
look like this they're like is there a
dead body
you know like they want to see that
moment of me getting stung or bit
with the jellyfish it's just a sensation
um
just like saying you know coyote are you
ever going to get sprayed by a skunk
well we thought about it except for the
fact that nobody watching can smell what
that looks like
and then i just have to suffer through
it for multiple days so there are
strategic
moves that we have made for things that
we've not done simply because the
audience wouldn't get enough payoff
yeah well you know with that said my
top performing youtube video of all time
is uh
the the peruvian jellyfish and really
yeah it's interesting too because
my dad makes his point a lot you know
that there's some certain things
it's like how bad is it really and how
much does it connect with the audience
sometimes things are like
wildly successful and they weren't
really that bad you know sometimes
things are [ __ ] awful and nobody
cares like for example
i jumped out of this sea glider aircraft
into the ocean with no parachutes going
live
looking at like i was the wind was
knocked out of me i thought i hadn't
turned
nobody cared nobody but then with the
peruvian jellyfish
it was not a man of war it wasn't it
wasn't like uh uh
you know one of these super crazy box
jellies it was a moon jelly
but it was a large moon jelly and i
pulled it out of the ocean i said it was
the jellyfish sombrero
so it was sombrero and then i plopped it
on my head where it just like you've got
it
covering your head like and it's like ah
it's
immediate the reaction to it so
uh that that was one that really really
connected people
were just oh my god i can't believe the
visual of that of it all
covering my whole head was and uh and
they have the association with jellyfish
of the box jelly of the man of war so
they think of jelly's
vicious gnarly when in fact a moon jelly
is not that [ __ ] gnarly
so that was a big win for me uh
you know and in my mind i've always
thought oh but i should do the man of
war i should do the box jelly
probably not man that like the box
jellyfish can legit
kill you or something so again it comes
down to that visual that people
i think really gravitate toward um
and it is fair to say paul you were
asking you know how do we up that
one next level um we've got a a
sub series that we're going to be
producing in 2021
where we actually take a different look
at certain stings and bites
that people can encounter in their
backyard right so i've been stung by all
these crazy things
what about the stuff that's not that
crazy that people are actually going to
run into in their backyard
and then we're going to take a different
scientific approach to say okay
this is the scenario that happens now
what do you do about it
so um that's a new thing we've got in
the works that you know we know people
will love to see that sting
moment from even commonplace things but
then being able to educate them with the
right steps to do
if the worst case scenario happens to
you like anaphylactic shock
we want to educate people on what to do
with that yeah i like it
now it's been said many times over and
over
it's almost a motto for jackass if
you're going to be dumb
you got to be tough and i'm just looking
i'm so
glad that my new dumb but tough
t-shirt is available and i'm so glad i
got to wear it on the episode with
coyote peterson
i mean dude i'm impressed by you you do
frankly you do dumb stuff and you make
it smart
and you're a tough guy you know what
about that hat this hat is
uh a dumb but tough hat as well yeah we
gotta
send it to coyote yeah i was gonna say
do i get one for being on the show
because i will definitely wear that
every day
uh you don't wear it every day but you
do have to work out a video that gets 50
million views
[Laughter]
man thank you so much for your time dude
i think uh you know
i wasn't sure what to expect and and you
absolutely you impressed me just
like what a good guy been a real
pleasure to talk to you
can we send anybody uh to what are we
sending them to bravewilderness.com
yeah you just search brave wilderness on
the internet you'll find the youtube
channel that's definitely your gateway
for all the animal
adventure content crazy bites and stings
tons of educational stuff
that's the spot to check out everything
right cool man
well brother um thank you thank you
did i tell you or what the guy's just a
cool dude
and you know who else is cool you are
for sticking around to the very end of
the podcast it means so much to me it
really does
and maybe you pay a lot of attention to
what i'm up to maybe you don't
but either way i just recently came out
with a mug mug what what's that mean
it's a coffee mug that has my
actual mug shot on it and i personally
think
it is so utterly genius that i can't
stand it
and i want you to grab yourself one at
stevo.com
okay is that too much to ask it's a
coffee mug
everybody loves coffee and what i don't
[ __ ] care i love you no matter what i
really do
so thank you for watching